[Musique]
après 20 minutes de route nous voici
presque arrivé à Avord dans le Cher
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouvel épisode de mon village alors avec
Coralie pierre derrière la caméra nous
avons choisi de venir à Avord
aujourd'hui puisque à bord est souvent
connu grâce à sa base aérienne la base
aérienne qui emploie d'ailleurs presque
plus de personnes que son nombre
d'habitants on va aller voir justement
si ces habitants ont autre chose à nous
raconter
bonjour
vous êtes le responsable c'est ça du
bureau de tabac on vient de tourner une
petite émission sur le village d'Avord
on se demandait à avoir à part la baisse
aérienne qu'est-ce qu'il y a d'autres et
bien par la base aérienne on a guilmo
qui qui donc une entreprise de
surgelés on va dire qui rayonne
jusqu'à Château Rouge je crois ils ont
même des dépôts à Châteauroux je crois
autrement il y a des commerçants
je fais partie et puis et puis que ces
commerçants dans son bien nécessaires
pour pour le village vous êtes installé
ici vous depuis combien de temps vous
avez vu l'évolution j'imagine de ce
village depuis très longtemps puisque là
je suis moi je suis là depuis 2005 moi
quand je suis arrivé il y avait quand
même beaucoup moins de monde puisque
depuis que je suis là il y a eu trois
constructions enfin trois comment dire
lotissement qui ont été construit donc
bah ça vient du monde obligatoirement
c'est les gens et puis on a 200 villages
tranquille donc la proximité de la base
la proximité du psych fait que on a
quand même une sécurité
peut-être par ailleurs
c'est important pour un village comme à
bord d'avoir un établissement comme le
vote qui fait ce hôtel restaurant alors
on le ressent on le ressent on a quand
on a ouvert les gens étaient impatients
parce que c'est vrai que
à part nous il n'y avait qu'un seul
restaurant il me semble c'était la
maison d'Angers donc ça diversifie un
petit peu
[Musique]
j'ai pas le permis personnellement donc
moi je prenais le train voilà donc c'est
bien pratique ça voilà merci à vous
bonne journée
c'est facile de vivre à avoir avec des
enfants c'est un village vivant oui ça
va ça va ça vit bien enfin il y a tout
ce qu'il faut boulangerie un commerce
école collège plein de choses c'est
important justement comme critères quand
on vient s'installer ici avec des
enfants d'avoir des écoles d'avoir tout
ce qu'il faut pour eux c'est très très
ben oui après quand ils vont plus quand
ils vont grandir ils ont le transport
aussi pour les écoles à Bourges donc il
y a tout ce qu'il faut même quand ils
grandissent
je me permets de rentrer je m'installer
à côté de vous
vous êtes installé ici depuis combien de
temps ça va faire un an il y a beaucoup
de jeunes commerciaux qui arrivent et
puis c'est bien c'est bien pour les
petits villages comme ça
dans les petits villages comme ça c'est
souvent des petites pièces après après
je fais de tout mais c'est souvent des
petites pièces merci beaucoup bonne
journée
c'est la fin de cet épisode tourner à
Avord dans le Cher vous retrouvez mon
village lundi prochain